on February 22nd 2022 a car crash in
Chicago escalated when one of the two
drivers pulled a gun and shot the other
one in the leg
while we don't know much about the
suspect we can assume that she had at
that instant limited capacity for
sympathy self-awareness empathy
metacognition and theory of mind
in short she could have liked social
intelligence and misinterpreted the
incident as a deliberate attack
foreign
telligence is the capacity to know
oneself and to know others sometimes
referred to as tact common sense or
Street smarts
it's an innate human trait of
neurotypical Minds that gets refined
through experience with people and
learning from success and failure in
Social settings five distinct cognitive
skills are at its core
foreign
sympathy is our tendency to feel with
others parents naturally sympathize with
their child and babies experience stress
when their mothers are sad
as we grow up most of us show a lot of
sympathy for our family some for our
close circle of friends and less for
strangers
self-awareness is the ability to
understand our feelings toddlers that
indicate they are hungry display that
capacity if they throw Tantrums it's
often because they don't understand
their emotions although some are
explicitly told not to express what they
feel
as we get older we gain better
self-awareness some people remain
confused by their feelings because they
have learned to suppress them
empathy is our ability to understand
what others are feeling some children
begin to show empathy as early as
kindergarten others seem to like this
ability even when they are far older
through years of social experiences we
can refine our empathy but those who
never quite learn to understand their
own emotions may also never learn to
sense the feelings of others
foreign
is an awareness of One's Own thought
processes at age four most children
display the first forms of metacognitive
skills when they begin to show what they
know and what they don't know soon after
they learn to assess their level of
confidence in their own knowledge
as adults many of us get to know our
brain and learn that one of its jobs is
to bring order to an inherently chaotic
world of fact and fiction
some however get trapped in the stories
and lies they tell themselves to be true
they don't see that their minds can get
stuck in a web of biases they remain
unaware that they may be wrong about
certain assumptions
theory of mind is our ability to
understand what others know and how they
think children start to demonstrate
theory of mind around the age of six
they then realize that others may have
different information and as a result
draw different conclusions this often
leads to more empathy
as adults theory of Mind allows us to
understand another person's perspective
and their pattern of thought which makes
it a powerful skill for influencing
others
so sympathy and self-awareness help us
to understand our emotions and
metacognition our thoughts they provide
us with knowledge about ourselves
empathy allows us to appreciate what
others feel and theory of mind what goes
on in their heads they allow us to
understand others
social intelligence is always formed
within a particular culture which means
we might be clueless when put into a new
social setting so while all five aspects
are universally present they need to be
refined for each particular society
Animals by the way show sympathy and
empathy chimps even show a rudimentary
ability for theory of Mind humans
however are the most socially
intelligent of all species
what do you think where does our high
social intelligence come from and how
could we develop the five traits further
to increase our understanding of each
other share your thoughts in the
comments below
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com